another pair of functions that we were
looking at uh the topic before linear
functions was
exponentials and logs right exponentials
and logs so if i do these quickly on two
separate diagrams
um so here's my exponential
and these are called exponential
functions
right again you pick an x value like x
equals zero
you only ever get out one y value and
because this is happening for
exponentials
it also happens for logs right i should
have put that asymptote in it
so we talk about logarithmic functions
right
so far so good we've seen all of these
okay but you notice
right we never ever well you wouldn't
notice this because we
it's something that we weren't doing we
never talked about circular functions
because circles are not functions are
they
right now it is worth noting on every
circle
there are two places that you can put in
one x value
and you'll get exactly one y value out
right there are exactly two
every circle which points are those on
this one for example
they're going to be the um the outsides
of the circle i suppose there's one way
of saying it so x equals one
you'll get one one y value only right
and x equals negative one you'll get one
y value only
okay now i guess that should be a
function is relation where
each x value i should say every x value
produces only one y value right so it
doesn't matter if some of them are okay
they tick the box and they give you one
y value every single one has to do
okay bless you so geometrically
what does this mean okay and this is
this is heading into our next little
terminology idea right a very crude way
of working out whether something is a
function or whether it
isn't is if you take
a vertical line right if you take a
vertical line
and if you put it up against your graph
right like say
here if you can put it up against your
graph and you can put up anywhere
against your graph
like so and if you go over here
right that's not vertical so there we go
close enough
if you can put a vertical line through
any part of your graph
and it only intersects once
then ticks the box it's a function
because that vertical line if it only
hits once what that means is there's
only one y value
okay but if you put it up against a
relation
and you draw your vertical line you're
in trouble right because you have
intersected twice so you no longer
pass the test okay so
under this idea of a function is a
relation where each x value produces
only one
y value therefore
you can determine whether something is a
function or not
right if it passes what we call the
vertical
line test this is a simple enough
idea right simple enough idea
now i'm just going to give you one tiny
little extension of this
um so you don't weird out when you see
it in the questions i'm going to pose
to you these are all really standard
relations that you see right linear
parabolic exponential logarithmic
um circles can you think of any other
kinds of shapes that you know about
the other kinds of shapes yeah
okay so a trig graph
a trig graph i'm so glad you said this
actually uh looks like this there's this
sign
for instance okay this if i put my axes
label them a little bit
if that's y and that's x this is y
equals sine x so far so good
yes so if i if i
take those two variables right and um
you know there's no problem with taking
variables
and switching them around for instance
if i take a straight line
like say what does that look like i
don't know 2x plus one or something like
that right
if i switch the variables around here
i just get another straight line you
happy with that
i'll skip the parabola for a second if i
go over here exponentials and logs right
if this is y equals two to the x okay
if i were to switch around the x and the
y
what would happen i'm going to get this
guy right because if i say x
equals 2 to the y i can just rewrite
this we just have
new terminology for it to say make y the
subject that's log base 2
of x okay so i've switched around the x
to the y
and i've gone from this kind of graph to
this kind of graph okay
come back to this one in a second
actually no i'll do it now
this looks like this right
so if i switch around the x and the y
and do this
what does it look like yeah
it's gonna yeah yeah how would you say
it how would you articulate it
oh it looks like i guess it's
like rotated rotated
yeah yeah yeah good it's going to look
something like this
all right now this is still a parabola
it's still a problem still the same
shape but it's gone um
it's gone sideways in much the same way
that this exponential function
right has kinda gone sideways when it's
become a lot now here's a problem with
this though right
the parabola here this parabola is a
function
right it passes my vertical line test
but
um once i switch them around
i don't pass anymore do i i've
intersected twice
now you think that's kind of that's kind
of bad you're right it is kind of bad i
don't pass the test anymore
right um but that's nothing compared to
if i
take this guy oh yeah yeah this guy
and switch him around right
now if i switch these variables again
like we've noticed it's going to kind of
turn
sideways it's going to look like this
okay now i'm just gonna tease this
because we'll get into this as a full
topic
later on right but does this guy pass or
fail the vertical line test
he fails and he fails and he fails over
and over again
because if you pick a line right
it doesn't just intersect once or twice
it intersects
infinitely many times in just the same
way that if i said oh when's sine x
equal to like a half
the answer is 30 and 150 and 390 and all
the answers after that right 5 10.
so infinitely many solutions this way
means infinitely many solutions
this way